[Music]
so a uh
driver recently
had just won uh by auction aka purchased
a new car for 704 thousand dollars
704 000 uh-huh it is a supercar a 2006
heritage edition for gt oh oh okay yeah
and then they're like super limited
right yeah yeah yeah shortly after
purchasing he smashed it into a tree oh
and completely trashed in front of the
vehicle it goes down in value when you
drive them off the wall
[Laughter]
they do say that they do say that they
sold it because you can't do that either
yeah yeah he smashed it into the tree uh
he's a 50 year old uh who had won this
auction and the reason why
he crashed it into a tree is because he
was unfamiliar with how to drive
stations
god
driven stick you're about to be at 50
and not knowing how to drive a [ __ ]
stick i'm buying a stick car that's 700
000. like if you're in your 50s today
you definitely know how to [ __ ] yeah
because that's all they had in here
dude
i drove my truck off the lot having no
idea how to drive stick but that was
worth twenty thousand dollars like this
is a [ __ ] crazy thing
dude i worked valet for years you know
like the requirement is you have to
drive stick you know how many people
didn't know how to [ __ ] drive stick
in valet i've heard that's the
screechings
that's all [ __ ] up that's total isn't
it that's [ __ ] up oh yeah it's over
it's over that's a palm tree too man
hey think about how confident he was
getting into the car [ __ ] started
he's like what's this what's his other
pedal hey man i won this [ __ ] [ __ ]
what
stupid thing is like even if you don't
know how to drive stick the brake is
still the same yeah
unless you're like no and then you don't
know and you press the clutch that's
probably what happened this dude puts
his sunglasses on he's like siri take me
to [ __ ]
right into the tree
man i just thought my nephew had a dry
stick and we like to rode this like 350z
oh you turtle to teach and just [ __ ]
it up
you can just smell the burnt clutch yeah
oh and that smells [ __ ]
return it to him and be like
it kind of smells like rubber i don't
know why
i don't know why it was like this the
clutch is all [ __ ] up dude you know
that's a good idea i think that's how
you do my girl how to drive like a car
yeah with someone else's car
he wants to drive his like his dad his
dad passed away and his dad left him a
really nice corvette limited thing so
we're like you're not gonna learn on
that thing you're gonna no you're gonna
learn on someone else's [ __ ] that's not
where you wanna [ __ ] learn you gotta
go
you guys ever watched these videos where
like super sports cars are getting
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
from what oh that's so satisfying like
oh they're just being dicks out in
public like trying to drive around
somebody in the rain and then he just
goes into the wall oh yeah
or like the mustang ones right
the two corvettes that were drag racing
on the road and they hit each other
good i guess yeah the instant karma ones
are so funny
and then they smash into something it
makes me so happy i could watch it i
could watch that [ __ ] for a week
straight and not even move and just piss
and [ __ ] myself
dude it's [ __ ] crazy oh god damn all
right
yo i hate those guys they drive my
street [ __ ] dude it's cathartic
i thought i had something i was like oh
i just processed everything you just get
me you get me prescribed medicine for
constipation i'm gonna send you a link
[ __ ] trust me
and this
are our pretty much manual transmission
cars like all discontinued now there
should be it's really well only for
sport it's it's they still do it for
like sports cars because people like
that but but a lot of times they're
doing like the like you know like the
negative plus
stuff yeah that's weird so you got the
option it's not cool looking at all
paddles just doing is actually faster
right it's technically faster but
it's not the thrill
you know what has a weird one is uh the
audi uh r8 that uh shift uh stick shift
it's like it's like the um m32 yeah like
they have it's like weird you see this
makes the [ __ ] quiver yep yeah yeah
this little thing
what do you do
no
they don't like it yeah they don't like
fingers as much as we think they do
yeah i'm finding out
[Laughter]
later in life
this yeah yeah you're grooving
two hands on the steering wheel it just
doesn't look sexy it doesn't look like
you're confident versus like this yeah
this [ __ ] yeah this is that artsy [ __ ]
right right right right right we're
intuitive
have you driven a right-hand drive stick
before it's pretty weird oh no i can't
even imagine it's crazy oh really yeah
oh yeah it's all on the other side yeah
well the clutch is still is the same
it's still on the left but it's just a
bunch of gasoline
yeah it's like brushing your teeth with
your office oh okay you know how to do
it yeah yeah but you just feel
unpracticed so it all feels virgin i'm a
crash for sure i'll be like that car
crash at 35 miles an hour oh [ __ ] what
an [ __ ] don't think about christmas
that's what i feel like he got into
first gear and then he just
yeah he just [ __ ] with gundam into a
tree it does that he thinks it's like
[ __ ] tissue paper
that's a [ __ ] excuse he was [ __ ] up
yeah for 35 miles an hour sick ass oak
tree i'm all right yeah
oh hey that's your [ __ ] right that's
your [ __ ] right
we all know chapelle loves college
i hope i hope when you leave by the way
we're like man that guy [ __ ] oak
trees
redwoods it was right under there
we didn't gel
[Laughter]
last year i was selling a motorcycle you
know you got to shift on those too and i
was selling some kid
um he took it for a test ride i was like
waiting at rite aid for him to come back
and he just didn't come back it was like
half an hour i was like this guy [ __ ]
stole my bike and then um i get a call
and it's this kid's dad and he goes hey
my son he's really embarrassed he
crashed your bike he dropped it on at
like a red light he doesn't really know
how to like shift he's unfamiliar with
it so he's just really embarrassed and
doesn't want to come back
and i was like well he that's his bike
now
i gotta say because that was a ryan's
story i was scared for a second yeah
he's gonna die guy disappears he just
disappeared usually in my stories of
friends they all die oh okay
we're on the edge of diversity every
time you start telling us this kid
didn't die he just he just what did he
do just he didn't die but the person he
killed like over and he just started
crying yeah he just called his dad he
was just sitting there calling his dad
and then his dad called me how old is
this guy yeah how old are you he was
like in his 20s i would beat the [ __ ]
guy what bro we throwing hands he's like
a film producer and everything he's a
fail producer
because i was like pretty pissed and
then his dad started bringing up he's
like well you know like i'll make things
right i'm a firefighter i served at 9
11. i was there when the tower was like
no way you're telling me all this stuff
i know yeah well yeah why did he give
you that information
that's incredible the kid finally comes
back and the bike's not that bad it just
it just downed so like the whole side is
scratched it's like yeah the pedal's off
and then he just comes down he's like
shoulder straight
so [ __ ] you're 20.
you better put those goddamn shoulders
down
[ __ ] rolling up like come on i feel
like you're a 12 year old dog his dad
hooks you up with a fdny t-shirt and a
[ __ ] dinosaur
that's something that's what he came
back with would i ever forget when i
said i had you taken care of i think i
just proved it
but all they did was buy it i was like i
don't care just buy the bike and then i
told the kid like yo your dad was
bringing up all [ __ ] about 9 11. and the
kid's like yeah my dad always does that
that's kind of his thing
so for every situation
he's got a united we stand tattooed
it was a bizarre [ __ ] thing
so wait did they keep they keep the bike
yeah he bought it he had to i told him
like dude it's your bike i'm not this is
now yours you should've said jokes on
you i don't think 911 happened
this